[Music]
these are the wounded sick and injured
of the Navy they are being taken from
wherever they were hurt or fell sick the
naval hospitals where they will get the
best possible medical care
[Music]
these men are suffering with everything
from wounds and burns received in battle
two broken ankles from falling off a
ladder cleaning windows some are sick
from physical causes like heart trouble
or pneumonia others are just as sick
from mental causes the NP or
neuropsychiatric patients all sick
people require treatment right now
you're chiefly interested in the
treatment of the mentally ill these men
are being admitted to the NP ward for
the most part they appear more or less
normal but if you look carefully you
will notice that some of them show
definite signs of their illness these
patients are really sick otherwise that
doctors would have never sent them to
the hospital at Hospital Corpsman you
will help in the treatment of many types
of mental illness and each one requires
a different approach
[Music]
all right Villa let's have a wrist watch
and wallet because we're gonna give you
a sharp
I lost my portable radio already well
all your stuff we'll be putting this bag
which isn't unbidden and then kept in a
safe Locker everything you leave with us
is listed right down here so we have a
complete record what about that radio
oh well I'll make a note of that right
now and I'll have the chief sent out a
tracer on it and now Noah
let's get that uniform off azshara feel
good after three days of the train
treatment of an empty patient begins
from the moment he arrives in the
admitting room everything that his done
for him makes him feel that the people
in the hospital are friendly and want to
help your manner approach and the way
you handle and be patients is of great
importance remember they are more
sensitive than those who are physically
ill these are the papers on Noah sir
thank you that's all have a chair
your name is Miller
how are you feeling my life
I didn't sleep for three days well we'll
try and you have to get some sleep here
this man looks dazed and slowed down a
condition which can develop either in
boot camp or in combat you've been in
the dumps too but you've always managed
to snap out of it because that's normal
this man can't without help any more
than he could set his arm if it were
broken or take out his own appendix a
smart Colin can give him that help and
start him on the way to recovery how
about the child looks pretty good to me
I shouldn't be here
I should be back with the ship I have no
business here
you know Miller the quickest way to get
back to the boys by eating a shout
tastes good yeah
Tyler come on Tyler
tastes good doesn't buy some milk now
I gotta get back to the ship sure but
the milk will taste good with those
spuds this Coleman is doing a darn good
job he is firm but kind so as not to
irritate the patient the next time it
will be easier for both of them and the
patient has made another step to
recovery while mill is having his first
square meal in days let's get a few
things straight about NP patience first
of all the patient is never fatty or
nuts he is sick and must be treated as
such
take Miller he isn't stubborn or
unreasonable because he doesn't want to
eat that's just a symptom of his
particular illness and the corpsman used
the right approach not all empty
patients will be the same there are many
different types of mental illness and we
are going to show you a few you will be
seeing most some will be slowed down
like Miller others tense and on edge by
cases of psychoneurosis or combat
fatigue you will see the unreliable
psychopath the very depressed suicidal
patient and the catatonic some may be
mixed up and excited others overactive
with more energy than they can use in
each case these symptoms will be
different and all required different
treatment it is the corpsman rather than
the doctor who will be with the patient
most of the time and for that reason the
corpsman must know his patients watch
their behavior and report anything
unusual the corpsman is the eyes and
ears of the doctor here is what I mean
how did Harris get along last night I'm
afraid he didn't get much sleep even
with the sodium amytal you prescribed he
seems awfully restless and confused this
morning I better have him see me the
first thing after sick call how's Noah
today well he's getting along fine sir
he ate everything we gave him and wanted
more information about the patient's
behavior is being given to the doctor so
he can follow the case closely
take Miller for instance the doctor is
now ordering him a needle shower and
spray in hydrotherapy as part of his
treatment
step back a little William Miller
[Applause]
there is another type of patient you
will see and probably quite a few some
will be in hospitals but most will be
treated in naval convalescent centers
this type of patient may not seem
particularly sick to you but he may be a
psychopath a case of psychoneurosis or
combat fatigue this kind of patient is
usually tense nervous jittery and often
makes a tough problem to manage take
combat fatigue for example yeah how do
you think you're doing you're supposed
to hit the deck or the others I'm here
to see that you do what's the trouble
this jerks trying to get me up you know
I can't sleep nights when I finally do
fall asleep he tries to push me out for
God's sake take it easy fella al here is
know he won't do it again but don't
forget you're still in the service and
we've got rules here whether we like
them or not
besides you're gonna get well a lot
quicker if you follow the gang now get
out there with your mates you miss
breakfast already I don't see why we
have to baby these gold bricks he's no
gold Rick you want a Unit Citation you
don't have to baby them just use your
head i watch this time to get up there
it's time to get out
why everybody's up an out you miss
breakfast hurry you can get a cup of
coffee
you've got something there they probably
couldn't sleep last night lots of things
that patients do here seem like plain
goldbricking and belly aching but
they're not they're symptoms of whatever
they've got clearly act nasty and
insulting at times but just keep your
sense of humor and don't forget that if
you get tough with them they'll make
your job that much harder and I guess
you're right
same goes for the Psychopaths he can be
a real troublemaker in requires whether
you're watching I knew they got fooled
by one yesterday
why sure I think it's gonna be fast well
that's the matter said he'd have someone
leave it for me at the main gate I just
saw he said it'll be all right
sure till 6:00 tonight hey I'll get to
see a double edited a just a minute
fella I better check with dr. Abbott
oh well dr. Adams Rubina's hello dr.
Adams all right mrs. Davis in Ward 7 sir
did you tell Curran he could leave the
hospital a day sir sorry doctor Adam
says no I don't understand it we just
left him uh who the hell is he think he
is anyway
well that patient was a pretty good liar
but a little challenge when he was
caught you've probably seen Psychopaths
just like that outside of hospitals too
because there are lots of them and lying
is only one of their symptoms one of the
most important parts of the Corman's
work is the protection of patients
sometimes from others and sometimes from
themselves if the patient is depressed
enough he may even attempt suicide that
is why he may be put in a room with a
special watch not for punishment but for
protection oh my god anybody can do it
I already every way is there anything I
can get for you all right
robert's up on task six city has his
mother's picture in history well look it
up for a sure what's the picture pretty
bad poor kid
feels about as low as you can hopefully
picture helping son Robert isn't he the
one we're supposed to keep an eye on
yeah that's the guy is he alone now oh
so I just come down here for a minute
yeah but it might be the wrong minute he
could kill himself in that minute that
man is supposed to get a shock treatment
this morning and he has a darn good
chance of getting well oh he probably
wants his mother's picture alright but
he might want this glass too and broken
glass can be awful sharp
you better get back up there on a double
okay when men are sick and depressed
like Roberts you've got to be on a
constant lookout for anything they could
use to hurt themselves glass in any form
medicine buttons eyeglasses or anything
that will make a sharp edge remove all
belts neckerchiefs
scarves watch out for knives razor
blades or anything that will cut you may
never see a patient as depressed as that
but if you do remember Roberts in his
mother's picture fortunately for him
there are several ways of treating his
condition one of the most successful is
the electroshock treatment they go help
[Music]
kinda hot putting that thing around
isn't it not too bad the exercise feels
good how the treatments going along I'm
through with them at six the doctor says
I don't need any more guess I was pretty
sick when I started taking those
treatments I don't even remember well
it's good to see you looking so well
it's things like that to give you a kick
out of working around an MP Ward to know
you helped that man recover makes you
feel good
of course not all patients will recover
so rapidly a lot of them may take weeks
or even months so don't get impatient
another type of patient you may help
treat is the catatonic
he may stay like this for hours or days
without looting eating or even speaking
but he hears and understands everything
[Music]
all right Harris we're going to see the
doctor now
[Music]
that seven and a half grain
[Music]
[Applause]
take it easy Harris the doctor wants to
talk to you
[Music]
sodium amytal please
[Music]
it's alright Harris this will make you
feel better
this medicine will help you to relax so
that you can talk to us
[Music]
all you feel pretty needles
gotta get off
[Music]
I want you to talk to his here
[Music]
we want to help you but you won't tell
us what's wrong
you know we want to help you to get well
don't you
everything I believe here that's fine
then tell us what's worrying you and why
you can't talk they tell me not to who
tells you not to voices but you see you
can talk I guess I can't
about these voices when you hear them
mostly at night just it's a good bet are
they male or female voices well it's one
that keeps threatening me starting with
this treatment and helped by various
others the patient will continue to get
better sometimes in a matter of weeks
well how's everything today Harris okay
got a light sure
was that really nuts when they brought
me here or what do you think guess I was
pretty sick yes you were funny thing it
must be nice to feel like yourself again
it sure is when do you think I could go
downtown to see a football game well I
don't know but I'll talk to the doctor
about it today
swell Frank's the corpsman played a
large part in the recovery of that
patient and still does he was honest and
not too optimistic in his answers you'll
get questions all day long from patients
so if you don't know the answer the
safest thing to say is I don't know but
I'll try and find out one of the most
serious problems on the NP ward is the
next up patient who becomes excited and
assaulted good morning tally well go
ahead go ahead and shoot me I'm not
going to shoot you Charlie
oh yes you are you're a police woman
it's your duty come on let's go it's
time he took a little rest no I can't
rest I deserve to be shot no you don't
Charlie come on let's lie down you've
got to shoot me I'm yellow no matter how
tough and unreasonable a patient is he
must never be manhandled if you are ever
in a spot like this get as much help as
you can lift the patient off his feet
take off his shoes and carry him into a
strong room then call the doctor
immediately
what seems to be the trouble tones don't
you want to talk to me about maybe
getting down the hydro for a cold pack
how do you feel that morning not so good
well the doctors ordered a treatment for
you again this morning you'll feel
better after you get your treatment
get a good'n tight down to the Kapadia
raise your head charlie
alright how's that comfortable that's
pretty good I'm gonna go to sleep now
there is another type of overactive
patient but he is not so mixed up he has
more energy than he can use sensibly and
takes careful handling like most envied
patients if handled improperly he will
behave improperly if you forget that he
is a patient and you are a common
anything can happen say these aren't the
magazine's you promised me what the hell
are they for about the tenth time
Bennett I'm telling you no see you
bought them as soon as I possibly can
now don't bother me I'm busy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this patient can be calmed down by a
continuous tub and hydrotherapy pause
attempt to run again turn about 98
degrees teeth better raise it to a
hundred fans been pretty excited
now all these extras power can be used
on something constructive and health
[Music]
to get the patient back into an
organized routine way feels himself a
member of the group is another part of
your job under the supervision of the
doctor occupational therapist and
corpsman organized activities like these
will help
most patients recover
[Music]
I haven't got time to show you in detail
the many things you may be doing as an
NP Coleman but I'd like to include a few
you may help the doctor in the EEG room
by taking a record of the patient's
brainwaves the corpsman is checking the
electrodes before making a record these
tracings often give the doctor valuable
information in certain brain disorders
you will be expected to take the patient
to the psychologist we're careful tests
are given to measure intelligence or
test certain skills you may have to take
him across the country on a train aboard
a ship
or in a plane under travel conditions
what you have learned becomes more
important than ever there is about five
times as much chance for suicide escape
or injury while traveling remember here
you're on your own and don't have the
protection of the hospital ward to help
you when he gets better you may have to
take him shopping or you may take
several patients to a ballgame or the
theater your job may seem tough at times
but men with your special training are
needed and when your ship mates leave
the hospital happy and well again
there's a lot of satisfaction in knowing
that you've done your part
use your wristwatch thank you know I got
a 30-day leave fly to be going hey will
you bet not that you fellas haven't been
alright thanks here's something else it
came in yesterday you must have left it
on the train hey that's swell you guys
never forget things do you this will
come in handy on that 30-day leave yeah
well thanks thanks for everything
sure good luck you see it right over
[Music]